تمديد الهدنه والمعارك ياتيان وسط الحديث
عن مبادره الايجاد التي طرحت يوم امس حيث
قبلت بضبابيه ردود الاطراف بشان الجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات فقد قلت وزاره
الخارجيه السودانيه في بيان لها انه لا
صحه لدخول القوات المسلحه في تفوض مع قوه
دعم السريع واضافت الخارجيه السودانيه انه
لا خيار امام قوات الدعم السريع سوى
الاستسلام او الفناء بحسب تعبير البيان
وكان الجيش السوداني قد ذكر في وقت سابق
امس ان قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
وافق بشكل مبدئي على مبادره من منظمه
الايجاد تضمنت مقترحات لحل الازمه الحاليه
وحسب بيان الجيش السوداني فان المقترحات
تتضمن تمديد الهدنه 72 ساعه اضافيه كما
تشمل المبادره افاده ممثلين عن القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع الى جوبا
للتفاوض